great everyone I'm Ilana and today I am
reacting to Outback Steakhouse
commercials anyone who is in familiar
with that name is a chain of Australian
themed restaurants in the United States
and I have been to one as an Australian
it is a national disaster but the food
was delicious but mostly just a bunch of
loosely scattered references to
Australia that didn't make any sense
whatsoever and I'm pretty excited to see
what these ads are like knowing what the
actual restaurants are like so let's do
it in the outback Wyatt doesn't judge
Mikey he creates flavor hurry in for a
look at a time our chefs they're cooking
up our tender would buy grilled sirloin
sweet chili chicken and shrimp that's
what we call our beyond tonight is this
the things people think happens it is
truly also the plugin is no rules just
right what does that mean about a
thousand miles from me every day there's
a place that's a bit more adventurous a
place that awakens you think like a kick
from an angry kangaroo
just driving come on into our backstage
well that wasn't just how to montage of
things but we're in Australia with a
blaring didgeridoo and just told people
to eat meat this isn't a travel ad that
was a weird choice in the outback we're
wishing you seasoned greetings treat
yourself to our wood fire grill bone-in
ribeye hurry in and try a new sirloin
Portobello
this one's mostly just a montage of
nice-looking meat which is fine binding
also the guy does actually seem to be
Australian so that's good and they
didn't make him like overdo the
Australian accent like you know might
make sure you come down and get some
steak from your local pub it could have
been what fun fact whatever I imitate a
heavy Australian accent I cannot do it
in a woman's voice I have to just have
to do it as a dude I don't know why yeah
g'day mate no it always sounds like man
introducing a CGI meats natural texture
and be sure to try out seasoned
perfectly grilled salmon salmon is adds
but I feel like in Austria that ain't
like cod or like whiting not really a
huge salmon country and a lot of prawns
no shrink oh my god you guys does a song
what
docile Burmese in the air cos you forget
then when you let's go out back
look out the diet go out back tonight
but the steak is thick and juicy the
shrimp is grilled and sweep the chicken
tender your only worry is which to
choose neither like I really like this
one because okay but anyone who doesn't
know Outback is basically like a really
far-out uninhabited pot of Australia
generally in the desert and it's like ah
you'll forget all your worries when
you're like that you probably get killed
probably going to die out there
trailers got lots of dangers on with you
probably not going to make it through
that night you know you're a true
outback fan when you think great
coverage none of this is real and around
a fillet great pics starting at 9:19 is
literally none of the trip go go go
it's like sick of all things crave on
yeah no that's just American football at
least you didn't try with that one like
I think I think they give it because you
want a tempting through you know all
right I'm gonna be honest that was not
too bad
there's nothing completely outrageous in
there just a lot of fluffy meat being
sizzle it was fine alright I will have
another video up on my Channel next does
a book full then I have to think some
other negatives on patreon
they are Brian McNally Michael Kim Clark
Kelvin Roger Duggan and Damon be thank
you guys so much I'll see you next time